after Trump was arrested booked and
arraigned for 37 felony counts related
to classified documents that include
obstruction uh and other crimes
Trump flew back to his Resort in New
Jersey Bedminster and he gave a speech
in this speech Donald Trump actually
admitted to some of the crimes he is
accused of misstated the law under which
he is being prosecuted wrongly said
other people also committed the same
crimes which by the way it's not really
a defense to say other people have also
committed these crimes it's just another
form of an admission and maybe most
importantly really seemed dejected and
as though he is extraordinarily scared
which reportedly he is really a speech
for the Ages which contained this
instant classic line from Trump I did
everything right and they indicted me
[Laughter]
it is truly Beyond parody but it is
really an important speech because this
speech is admissible legal experts have
written overnight that even if uh Donald
Trump doesn't testify in this trial
or what may be an eventual trial the
speech he gave last night is admissible
as evidence and in last night's speech
uh he actually admits to much of what he
is accused of doing let's Dive Right In
the Sham indictment put forward by the
Biden Administration included stage
photographs of boxes at Mar-A-Lago many
people have asked me why
I had these books is why did you want
them
so remember he says the boxes are staged
but actually they are his boxes and now
he explains why answer in addition to
having every right under the
presidential records Act is that these
boxes were
containing all types of personal
belongings many many things shirts and
shoes and everything
as can be seen in the picture where
someone not me
I wonder who it might have been
dumped one of the very neatly arranged
boxes all over the floor
they were full of newspapers press
slippings thousands of pictures
thousands and thousands of White House
pictures
the White House photographers some are
with us today they took so many pictures
and we saved all of them and they were
in those boxes
clothing memorabilia and much much more
I hadn't had a chance to go through all
the boxes it's a long tedious job takes
a long time so understand that amidst
the bad audio and the sniffing from
Trump there are a bunch of different
defenses there it's hard to keep track
he he Declassified them when he was
president except this doesn't have to do
when he was president the FBI planted
them he called them planted boxes But
ultimately what Trump is saying is it
was my right to have those I simply
hadn't gone through them yet because I
was really busy that is an admission to
some of the critical facts that I don't
believe his lawyers are even looking to
stipulate if this eventually goes to
trial Trump digging his own hole Trump
then referring to his rights as
president of the United States but again
it's really important to understand
Trump's getting himself into more
trouble here because he is not indicted
for his conduct as president of the
United States the president enjoys
unconstrained authority to make
decisions regarding the disposal of
documents the problem is this is not for
things Trump did as president and we
know he didn't declassify those
documents because there's audio of him
saying these are classified documents
from July of 2021 unconstrained
to make that decision neither the
archivist nor Congress has the authority
to veto the president's decision
the presidential records act does not
confer any mandatory or even
discretionary Authority on the archivist
to classify records folks under the
statute this responsibility is left
solely
to the president of the United States
think of Donald Trump was not president
when he committed the alleged acts for
which he has been indicted this is it
seems like just Trump reading stuff off
of one of the very teleprompters he
criticizes others for using it seems
like it's just more of that but legal
experts have looked at that 37 second
video clip and come away realizing Trump
is admitting to crimes and he is also
stating law
presidential records act I guess we can
call it law that is not the law under
which he is charged and Jack Smith the
special prosecutor has Trump on a
recording saying that the things he had
were still classified meaning he knew he
did not declassify them this is going to
become evidence after bemoaning the
politically motivated prosecution
against him uh in which he claims Joe
Biden was involved even though there's
no evidence Joe Biden was involved in it
Trump actually says out loud out loud if
he becomes president he will go after
the bidens for politically motivated
reasons look at this I will appoint a
real special prosecutor to go after the
most corrupt president of the history of
the United States of America Joe Biden
and the entire Biden crime family
name a special prosecutor
now you understand that people in the
background are yelling lock him up about
Joe Biden these are the people who claim
Trump wasn't given due process and they
want Biden locked up absent forget about
an indictment absent any evidence of
Criminal Intent which we will get back
to
and all others involved with the
destruction of our elections our borders
and our country itself they're
destroying our country
and when I'm re-elected and we will get
reelected we have no choice we're not
going to have a country anymore I will
totally obliterate the Deep State we
will obliterate
so Trump going conspiratorial but if you
are on the right and you are claiming
that we are a Banana Republic because
Trump was indicted Trump is straight up
saying we're gonna go after the Biden's
period full stop no due process no
evidence Trump also referred to the
documents in question as his own papers
and his own documents they are not that
I mean by law that is not what they are
these are the government's documents
these are the people's documents Trump
just like these are my documents they're
not your documents charging a former
president of the United States under the
Espionage Act of
1917.
wasn't meant for this an act for a crime
so heinous that only the death penalty
would do and threatening me with 400
years in prison for possessing my own
presidential papers which just about
every other president has done they are
not Trump's papers they are not Trump's
papers sort of mob-like trump attacking
the wife of special prosecutor Jack
Smith just going after his wife
he's a raging and uncontrolled Trump
hater as is his wife who also happened
to be the producer of that Michelle
Obama puff pieces total puff piece
this is the guy I've got yep going after
the wife of the prosecutor claiming that
the doj evidence was staged no other
president even those who kept far more
documents than I has ever
been even investigated let alone charged
with a crime
because the Sham indictment put forward
by the Biden Administration included
stage photographs of boxes at Mar-A-Lago
many people have asked me why
I had these boxes there is no evidence
that the photographs were staged there
is no evidence that Joe Biden did a damn
thing and then lastly moving on to Biden
and Hillary did it too which is not a
defense this Corvette is stored he's so
proud of that car
there was no security and the door was
left open most of the time it was open
all of those classified documents all of
those documents strewn all over the
floor piled up like junk
unlike me who had absolute
declassification Authority as president
Joe Biden as vice president had no
authority to declassify and no right to
possess so the normal stuff I don't have
to play the whole thing for you but
blaming Hillary and Biden for doing the
same thing isn't a defense and it's also
not true first and foremost the Hillary
Clinton circumstances there was an
investigation which concluded that there
was a complete and total lack of
Criminal Intent remember that the
indictment against Trump involves
willfully retaining these documents
refusing to give them back lying about
having them obstructing going out of his
way it also includes recordings with
alleged conversations where Trump
actually signals that he knows exactly
that those documents are classified it
is simply not an analogous situation
whatsoever to Hillary Clinton's as far
as Biden there's a special counsel
investigating that I mean we we just
haven't gotten an answer one way or the
other if Biden did something wrong
indict him for all I care but as of
right now saying Biden and Hillary did
it too is partially premature completely
Incorrect and dramatically misstates
what Trump has even been indicted for
Trump's speech will likely be evidence
against him if you can imagine it is
clear Trump is not taking advice from
his own lawyers to the extent that he
can even retain lawyers after the break
let's see what the Trump supporters
think about all of this
one of our sponsors today is replace
your mortgage mortgages are a really
interesting thing in the United States
the poor often can't afford them and the
rich often don't use them instead the
wealthy use special Financial tools to
pay off their debts often in a fraction
of the time that it takes for a
middle-class American to realize that
same payoff replace your mortgage
teaches you how you can pay off your
home in five to seven years without
needing to make more money than you're
currently making right now and in
addition they can teach you how to
better utilize your existing assets and
Equity to beginner continue growing
wealth and passive income through
additional strategies and they actually
have an upcoming Workshop that will show
you how you can take advantage of these
strategies how it all works create your
own economy in a sense you can go to
replace your universe city.com slash
Pacman to watch the interview I did with
their founder Michael Lush to learn how
you can get exclusive access to what can
be a life-changing virtual event the
link is in the description